Hello, welcome everyone. It is the 22nd
of April 2025. We're in active inference
gueststream
104.1 with Tadhiro Tanaguchi. We will be
hearing a presentation and a discussion
on collective predictive coding and
active inference. a new perspective on
emergent communication. So, thank you
for joining and looking forward to the
presentation. Okay, thank you very much.
I thank you very much for giving me this
great opportunity and speak at this
great live stream. So, I'm Taniguchi
from Kyoto University, Japan. Okay,
today I will talking about collective
practical coding and active inference a
new perspective on emergent
communication. So maybe collective maybe
uh for many of you the corrective
predictive coding maybe a new term and I
would like to uh introduce the this our
theory. Okay. So before starting let me
introduce myself.
I'm and actually the uh I have been
working on the simple emergence for a
long time and but in more pro sense the
AI and robotics and especially cognitive
developmental robotics is my
background. Okay. Last year I moved to
Kyoto University and I'm now the
professor at uh Koto University in
Japan. So if you have a chance to visit
is a beautiful city, please stop by our
laboratory. Okay. Anyway, uh let me
start. So before uh starting uh let me
let me share the key key points of
today's talk.
So I will propose
the collective predictive coding CPC in
short as a dynamics underlying symbol
emerging system. I will explain what is
symbol emerging systems later as well
and present a formulation of uh rangage
emergence based on probabilistic
genative models showing its relationship
between to the free energy principle and
active influence.
So also position CBC as a natural
generalization of FP to the group or
societal
level and presents the CPC
hypothesis as an interpretation of why
large models appear to understand the
structure of the physical world and also
introduce new perspectives
uh derived from or inspired uh by CBC.
BC such as CBC as a model of science and
quad process theory. Maybe the topic
will maybe be too much but uh I would
like to introduce our
idea. I hope it is exciting. So and
before diving into today's main topic
maybe the CPC as I mentioned CPC will be
a uh new term for you and let me
introduce the corrective predict coding
CPC hypothesis briefly but this uh
hypothesis extends the idea of
predictive coding to social and
linguistic phenomena.
So it states that simple systems
including language are formed through
collective the predictive coding by
humans. So in other words simple
emergence or language emergence can be
understood as a social representation
learning process. So as a result the
structure of the world may be encoded in
distributional semantics
uh in language. So the hypothesis also
suggests that this is why appear to
understand the world they inherit this
structure through vast amounts of
distributed human genetic
text. Okay. So and the main topic is CPC
and the free energy principle and so on.
But uh let's let me choose the LM as a
starting point of today's talk maybe
because everybody knows
recently. Okay. So
um we have but what are they actually
based on? So they are completely reliant
on human language
data. Okay. So let's take a moment to
reflect on our linguistic lives our
language human language. So actually as
I showed on this
slide on this slide. So each individual
we uh possesses a unique set of uh
linguistic and the world knowledge but
no one has complete knowledge or master
complete knowledge of language or
knowledge of the world. So and actually
we dynamically learn even when we when
we were children or infant. So we
directly learn and adapt our linguistic
knowledge through
communication and including reading,
writing and conversation. So rockage
system itself is not a concrete uh fix
system. So that is always changing and
that is at some have say above
ourselves. So nobody has complete the
language system. Importantly uh through
uh communication the language system as
I said the itself evolve over time.
uh in recent human history the vast
amount of linguistic data have been
accumulated in massive data sets uh on
the internet or server. So by training
uh by training on this corpora using
next prediction and uh also of course we
can use some reinfor learning method.
The large neural networks have
internalized the distributional
structure of human language. As a
result exhibit exhibit surprisingly high
level of uh language understanding and
usage. uh this achievement makes a major
discovery of the past decade and indeed
a significant milestone in a human
history I think but but as I mentioned
so this capability is very much relying
on our language that we
created. So the question remains how
does humanity form language in the first
place? How do we share meaning without
directly accessing the each other's
minds? How did society create a language
system without any centralized learning
process? These profound questions
motivated us to engage in constructive
research on language evolution and
language learning and symbol
emergence. And actually the I have been
we have been working on the this kind of
constructive
study uh since around 2010 the our
community has been studying simply
emergence in robotics se in
short takes a constructive approach to
cognitive system inspired by
developmental robotics. So actually we
developed many unsped learning method
and artificial cognitive systems for
multimodel object categorizations and co
concept formation language acquisition
from speech signals and so on. So better
to better understand human developmental
cognitive systems and the emergence of
language. So actually recently this kind
of self-s supervised unsupervised
learning uh or margin model data is very
very common recently but uh 15 years ago
it was very very characteristic research
uh to my understanding to my knowledge.
Okay. So and also the most of our models
were based on probabistic genetic model
and predictive models. In other
words, we uh okay and we defined the
symbol emergence in robotics in this
research series of research as
constructive approach to symbol emerging
systems. Okay. And as a part of this
animal research we have been working on
uh not only you mean the the working on
the world models and the predictive
coding as well in collaboration with
co-authors from the active inference
community. We have published a several
papers on this topic. So for example we
call that world models and predictive
coding for cognitive and developmental
robotics along with alongside uh robotic
neuroscientists and cognitive scientists
and we also contributed to uh a paper on
world model learning learning and
inference where professor carson served
as a first
author. Okay, these are the kind of uh
background of my research before getting
into the CPC like topic. All right. Uh
let me briefly uh let me begin let me
briefly introduce the simple emergence
system the term another term important
term in this talk. So this this figure
provides an overview of the
concept but let me um briefly introduce
the main idea here. The system does not
means artificial system or a robot or
something like that like that. The
system here refers a complex system that
enables symbol systems
uh uh including language to emerge.
The core idea is that the symbol
emergence involves a two key dynamics
happening
simultaneously. So you have individual
agents learning internal representations
forming concept through physical
interaction with the uh with the world.
Uh it it kind of embodied the
interaction the active interaction with
the world. The traditional studies in
development around cognitive robotics
and also our symbol emergency robotics
focused on this individual
representation learning process and
still many AI studies are looking at the
individual capability
uh of the language learning and other
skills. But uh at the same time these
engines interact socially through
semiotic communication communication
using symbols or signs including
language ex and it's uh through this
social communication that uh share that
that agent share the symbol systems and
uh through that process symbol systems
emerges across process group and this
emergent system then influence the
emergent symbol system then influence
individual perception communication and
behaviors in a top down manner. It's a
kind of top down constraint. So the uh
SCES simple emerging system mark
emphasizes the interplay between
individual learning and the collective
the behavior and kind of bottom up
formation and top down top down uh
constraints. This kind of micro group is
the heart of the simple emerging systems
and I believe this is the crucial part
of our language.
The after proposing this discrete lifted
model from the viewpoint of emergent
systems, I have been studying this
system to uncover the fundamental
mechanism of the human cognitive and
collective intelligence in terms of
symbols and
language. Of course, of course the there
are bunch of there are so many as
related prior studies.
The researchers have been studying
constructive approaches to language
evolution and emergent communication for
a long time. So for example in 1990s
Lucas in Europe and other researchers
pioneered
uh language game experiment you know
where agents form sign through
interactions. So many algorithms are
proposed and most of them are based on
language game. So the two agents or
several robots play some sort of
communication uh including the naming
game or differential games and through
that process they become sharing the
signs and uh you know symbols or form
language or something and so and more
recently and after the you know after
the after the deep learning became
popular and deep learning
deep reinforcement learning based
approach have gained gained popularity
and uh that changed the landscape of the
emergent research on emergent
communication. Okay. But uh basically
the how to say the central idea was
similar I think is similar and uh and uh
you know I can I can talk about the kind
of pros and cons of this approach but uh
uh you know the because of time
constraints let let me simply introduce
another line of research our approach on
emergent communication.
based on genetic model, probabilistic
genetic model which has been employed in
a series of study on simple emergence in
robotics our uh say our uh research and
uh say the answeric based approach okay
so I mentioned the main game so I didn't
uh talk about the example but uh uh we
extended or we changed the theoretical
basis of naming game and proposed
metropolis hastings naming game a bit
complicated name but uh that has a
reason the why we call this metropolis
hastings naming game uh this is a kind
of game language game built on a solid
mathematical foundation okay let me
introduce how does it
Back first uh there are two agents.
Consider agent A as a speaker and agent
B as the listener. The both agents both
agents observe the same object here. So
this means uh they we assume joint
attention. Joint attention is the
fundamental basis of the our language
acquisition. Basically the when infants
uh infants
around five nine months
uh old become able to perform the joint
attention and the joint attention is
believed to be the basis of uh language
learning. So I think this is a very uh
very natural
assumption. Okay. The next speaker names
the object
probabilistically and as that the naming
is uh performed by sampling from the
posterior distribution of a name based
on this image and the latent variable in
that representation.
The listener then decide whether to
accept the naming based on a certain
probability uh which depends on the
belief state. Specifically, this
probability reflect how well the
listener's belief matches the name uh
proposed by the speaker. So this agent
does not find the incoming sign
believable.
So it can reject the proposed naming
that this ability to reject uh is
crucial. After communication the
listener updates the internal parameters
related to representation learning and
naming. Then uh they switch ro and agent
B becomes a speaker and the game
continues. Overall this is a very very
simple game but it captures essential
dynamics of how shadow symbol can emerge
through communication. Okay. Uh let me
add let me continue the explanation from
the mathematical
viewpoint. Okay. If the acceptance
decision is made according to this
probability this probability
uh we can we can prove we can
mathematically prove that the name game
is equivalent to the metal processing
algorithm of basian inference of the
latent variable shown in the figure on
the right this w let's begin with a
graph with this graphical model Here O A
and O B uh represents a visual
observation of each element. Of course
they can be the multimodal
uh information uh that can involve other
sensor input but anyway uh they have
observations that is internal
representations a latent variable. We
also assume the existence of a variable
W here which serves as a prior of these
two
observation two agents. Okay. uh if we
treat W as a latent
variable this graphical model becomes
becomes very similar to multimodel or
multibu variational autoenccoder or some
multimodel representation learning
system.
So and if the two
agents two agents brain were directly
connected and could use both
observations
simultaneously. Okay, they could jointly
update the shared variable W and this
variable would encode the combined
information from both agents input.
However, in reality they are independent
cognitive systems. Do we humans cannot
directly connect our brain? So let's
introduce a trick
uh
algorithmically algorithmically we can
decompose the model into two part and
the left hand side represent agent A
right hand side represents agent B. Then
we consider a alternative inference
method for
W. So now think about the sampling
process. Agent A propose a candidate
latent variable WD by sampling from its
posterior
distribution and
uh and uh this value is passed to agent
B and who then decide whether to accept
the sample based on a certain
probability. If acceptance probability
is designed appropriately, this process
becomes equivalent to metropolis
hastings algorithm which uh some of you
may recognize as a march
montg method under certain condition and
this uh guarantee that she sign are
formed and that the categories emerge uh
among agents to approach approximate the
posterior distribution based on agents
uh observations because this is complete
the same as much uh model variational
autoenccoder
mation autoenccoder like s like say okay
uh this is the kind of the theory the
basic bas basic theory and of course we
can test this kind of system on some
data set okay the simplest one is always
aminest. Now let's move on to the result
of the experiment. Uh we conducted a
small experiment. Agent A observes the
amun data set and agent B observes
rotated uh amun data. You know in in for
example in learning process even even
though we have joint attention when
mother is pointing oh this is zero or
this is one or this is two the infant or
child look at the object uh from a
different direction. This is imitating
such kind of
situation. Okay. and uh we let the agent
play the meta voice h6 naming game.
Okay, this is simple result. So uh
simply uh this result if the agent do
not perform communication the
performance is like this no
communication
setting the and if the agent perform the
metropolis async naming game they can
see a sign they can share a sign and
actually the performance of clustering
is
improved. So this is because in the
learning process the categorization
process invol involving representation
learning process depends not only on
single agents observation but also on
both agents
observation the information is rich and
the result becomes better. So this is
wrong that that don't forget that uh
this this metropolis hing naming game is
a inference process of this march view
uh march view uh representation learning
system of course with a single view.
Okay. So without communication with the
the the the agent can only use the image
data. the agent observes but through the
emergent communication they
mathematically they theoretically make
use of the information as another agent
of day.
Okay, this implies that the similar
emergence in society is not only for
emergent communication but also for
better representation learning in better
understanding of the world and that's a
very important implication I think so in
that paper uh I published two years ago
we conducted the experiment on slightly
different set and I a similar result was
obtained observed
Actually if we are based actually if we
are based on this kind of
modeling this gave us a different view
of simotic communication communication
using symbol
signs. Here the communication is inter
interpreted as an interpersonal kind of
crossodal influence.
First agent A observes the object and
infer the latent variable. The sampling
and sampling samp
uh the
what and uh and after that based on a
given sample the receiver can
reconstruct the
observation. If the agent perform the MH
metrop naming game, they shall sign and
also agent B the after receiving that
message successfully
reconstruct deconstruct yeah reconstruct
the image of the
fruit. Okay. And interestingly please
see the old acceptance condition. All
acceptance condition means the listener
agent never reject the incoming sign.
Always they listen to the speakers the
and her say uh learn the learn something
from their level their uh
word. Interestingly, if we make the
agent accept all samples and the agent
do not use their belief states for
rejection, they could not successfully
form nice representation internally. As
a result, they cannot bring the images
from science. It's very interesting. I
think this uh because this is because
the communication without rejected
decision diverse from the theoretical
posterior sampling the basian influence
approximate basian influence. Okay. And
this is kind of first step the of the
our
journey. And following this the study we
have continued to explore the metropolis
hastings naming game and emergent
communication based on this kind of
robistic genetic model modeling. The
recent research has introduced several
key extensions to improve scalability
and structure and adaptability
including expansion to multiple agent
not only two but three or four or more.
The expansion to compositional language.
In the previous scenario the agent just
use kind of the A or B or she
categorical categorical signs. But uh
now the agents can use uh uh say the
sequence of tokens like sentence not
only has discrete sequence. So actually
the the agents can use continuous
signals as well.
So uh also the you know uh the the
uh in emergency communication not only
in this kind of naming or captioning
something like that. So cooperation is
important. So the one of the main field
of emergent communication is uh much
agent reinforcement running with
emergent communication. So actually the
thanks to the probabilistic modeling and
the controllers as inference framework
you know now the remote learning model
based learning can be
interpreted as a proistic inference. So
we successfully integrate our idea to
merge agent reinforcement learning as
well. So and we can use this kind of
emergent communication for uh for uh
making agent run cooperative behavior as
well. And also uh we we our idea our
original idea was based on metropolis
hastings
uh algorithm that is a kind of
approximate basian inference and of
course metropolis hastings algorithms is
not the only solution for such kind of
uh implementation. So uh we are now
developing a variational inference based
and contrastive learning based approach
and they are very they can get a similar
result uh with uh this and let me
introduce the one very very decent work
and actually the the we uh we uploaded
the display print uh one or two weeks
week weeks ago and the
the Okay. Now we want to the use we want
to connect our emergent communication
like research to the current recent
trend the of
AI and uh we the how say we replace the
visal autoenccoder and the gausian
mixture model like uh uh the previous
model with by the visual language model
visual language model. So naming naming
can be replaced by captioning you know
the agent can observe the natural image
and pray captioning you know.
So uh mas at all extended the metropolis
hing naming game to image captioning
using vision language model. As they
introduced we introduced a language
model GPD2
uh into the capture generation process.
In this scenario agents were pre-trained
on different data sets and attempt to
adjust their expression through
communication.
But more specifically, one agent is was
trained with cocoa data set and another
agent uh learned uh how say trained with
uh conceptual captions. So very
different the way of captioning you know
type of expression they have. So and but
uh through the process the their way of
captioning
uh is become become similar became
similar you know and uh I'm not I will
not get into the detail uh today but uh
if you are interest if you are
interested uh please take a
look okay and also as we found that uh
this kind of process Yes, even prevent
the catastrophic forgetting that was a
problemic uh how say problem in the fine
tuning in BM as well this may be a uh
engineering aspect but uh uh I think uh
it
has much implication anyway okay these
studies along with the idea of viewing
symbol or language emergence as
decentralized patient
have led us to new concept and that is a
collective coding of
CPC. Uh the idea is something like that.
So through the creation and negotiation
of symbols or symbol systems societies
may optimize collective world models.
This perspective suggest a social
extension of the free energy principle.
Uh later I will talk about this a bit
more uh in detail.
Uh okay. And uh and uh I think this is
very much inspiring
idea and uh I think so human
society is operating the same mechanism
same things and uh I'm I'm
wondering actually uh human when when
humans play. When people play the
similar naming game, are they following
the similar acceptance ratio or
rejection ratio? I mean that if they
follow the similar the rejection ratio
acceptance ratio that shows we are
humans can perform the basia inference
posterior inference together as a group.
So the we've conducted the you know the
this kind of exper experiment with
participants. So sometimes the in the
study of semiotics.
So they use uh this kind of experimental
setting. This is called experimental
semiotics and uh as a result uh the
result supports the idea uh that the
human language uh you know this humans
follow the metropolis the uh follow the
similar pattern to the metropolis hing
naming game. Um this is a very very weak
evidence I think but uh this uh
relatively support the idea that uh
human language evolution language
follows a CBC like mechanism to a
certain extent I think okay so and uh
and uh
let's okay so we have been building many
algorithms the with the idea
of that emergent communication or a
simple emergence can be viewed as a kind
of the genative model generative
process. So and reviewing uh these works
and considering future perspective
perspective uh we recently wrote a prep
titled uh genative emergent
communication large language model as a
collective world
model. Uh in this paper we expressly
argue that the large language model can
function as a collective world model in
a sense. So let me go back to the the
starting point of today's talk. I talked
about the light language models learning
process you know we have a simple
emergence system on right hand side you
know so and uh we now have the
collective the idea of collective
predict coding this is a kind of
representation learning performed by
everybody and usually when we talk about
the representation learning it's often
it almost
always consider it is a kind of internal
representation of love. But the symbol
emergence the process of symbol
emergence in the process of simple
emergence we actually create form the
external symbol systems. So like like
language and uh some subnowledge and so
on and uh that that process can be
regarded as a kind of social
representation learning or or the
representation learning external
representation learning performed by
multi agent systems.
So in some sense language embodying
collective
intelligence that is the how to say then
and then there with this perspective we
can now say that our language system is
structurally the modeling the
representing the structure of the world
but this is this is not a kind of
objective word it's a kind of the sum of
our subjective and perceptual embodied
experience. thought but as a result and
by internalizing this structure through
predictive modeling the LM re I would
say reconstruct such kind of world model
internally that is a scenario and uh and
many I think that this uh I think that
this is uh one idea that can uh
that as as a kind of the why is is so
working
well. Okay. So the let me move on to the
let me re illustrate the CPC hypothesis
again CPC again basic idea of emergent
communication and pre predictive coding
or free energy principle. First let's
start from predictive coding or world
model learning. uh there is a
person that he uh internally has
internal representation or world models.
Uh we are living with action perception
loop. This is very uh how say uh this
this is very popular way of describing
the the agent interacting the world. So
and uh and uh this process is uh based
this is regarded as a kind kind of
inference process. Okay. But uh we
humans we are so many and uh and uh but
and also the this interaction this
process is not uh informationally uh pro
probabilistically independent.
So yes uh we have communication and we
are influencing each
other. Following the proive coding
hypothesis through language here we can
form uh language like social
representation through the learning
process. I think through this process we
model and adapt to the world
collectively.
So uh this is the CPC but CPC process
explaining the the uh simple margin but
but with this view we can change
uh we can change our view until now we
believe that each person is an
independent and autonomous agent but
let's change the viewpoint first
language is here language is a kind of
autonomous system here.
Okay. And uh and uh language has sensor
sensors. That's us. Language uses us to
model the world through interaction.
From this point, we are subordinate to
the language system. Actually this kind
of view is often mentioned in
sociology and some other academic
fields and we are kind of the kind of
you know the
uh people working for
language. Okay. I think this kind of
dual viewpoint is very interesting to
extend our view of cognition uh to the
social
view. Then let's move on to the free
energy
principle. Okay. Recently we
formalized the CPC from the viewpoint of
free energy principle. Based on a
genative model representing CPC, we can
naturally derive variational free
energy. Uh in interestingly final form
can be divided into two
parts. The first one is an ordinary free
energy term. This is a sum of the
variational free energy of a number of
agent.
In addition to that, an interesting term
pops up. We call this the
collectiveization term. This term try to
align agents external representations W
with each other's internal
representation.
With this time the problem of minimizing
individual free energy becomes the
minimization of free energy of a single
of a single total system. Then actually
this is this free energy is not for a
single agent but uh actually that this
language that this total system free
energy is uh defined like this and they
are divided into the the individual free
energy and some mysterious collective
regularization term. I think this view
can extend the free energy from energy
principle from the individual to the
collective level with a clear
relationship to simple
emergence and
actually the this is related to the
classical senotics. I think uh
corrective meanization term is
particularly interesting from the
perspective of semiotics in semiotics
that he is Charles Sanders the father of
semiotics and arbitrariness is a crucial
concept science can represent arbitary
object depending on language culture
society and context so while this is
widely recognized To human knowledge, no
studies in sigotics have explicitly
addressed the functional role of this
arbitariness. For the from the
perspective of simple emergence, we can
argue that this arbitrariness provides a
degree of freedom that allow us to
optimize corrective variational free
energy. So this shift uh individual free
energy minimization problem into a
collective free energy minimization uh
framework. So in other words while we
rely on the plasticity of individual
brain we become a collective social
intelligence by exploiting the
plasticity of similar systems.
So these are my current speculative
thoughts on human
intelligence. Okay. So uh before
wrapping up my talk so I want to uh talk
about a bit more a bit several uh one or
two topics. So and this gave us further
inspiration about the temporal aspect of
human mind. So many of you may know uh
the dual process theory sometime it is
called the system one and
two. So uh that tells us we human have
fast thinking and slow
thinking. So C CPC gives us an
opportunity to extend this idea to group
level. So uh in our paper we discuss the
system 0123 a quad process theory for
multi time scale embodied corrective
cognitive systems. The CPC hypothesis
allows us the emergent symbol system as
a type of supercognitive system that
adapt to its embod environment with
extremity through temporal dynamics.
Okay. The first uh we have a kind of
physical dynamics. The even the some of
you may know like passive dynamic worker
and soft robotics they shows that even
without brain our body itself interact
with the world the so
uh so flexibly if you have a kind of the
the sufficient uh you your body have a
sufficient mechanical property. So this
is a kind of super fast dynamics and
this is important in robotics and often
missed in the AI studies and yes the
after that the in our you know cognitive
process first dynamic system one and
system two and actually the recently the
system one is modeled by world model and
predictive learning and imitation
learning and so on and the system to the
language level. The kind of derivative
sort that uh uh is modeled by language
large language model
recently. But this is how these are
happening internally inside of our mind
but uh as a group we have more slow
super slow
dynamics. It is the learning process is
corresponding to the kind of the
negotiating our symbol systems changing
our customs habit in our society that is
a more slower dynamics.
So and importantly system three and
system two zero are happening outside of
our mind but uh but uh the it is super
important for the our society and
ourselves we really have to this as
system
three
the hai uh Dr. Professor Hayi who is a
fifth. Okay. And following this work we
wrote another perspective paper
exploring the formalization of
scientific activity using the CBC. The
idea of CBC is a symbolic system emerged
through the organization of external
representations as human attempt to
model the world. You know this concept
closely aligns with scientific activity
even rather than language learning as
one of the fundamental goal of science
is construct external representation
systems that describe and enhance our
understanding of the world ultimately
improving our predictable capabilities.
So and uh okay one of the key insights
is that image name in symbol emergence
has an interesting similarity to
scientific discussion. So a
representative for
uh of scientific discussion is a kind of
peer review process. You know an agent
perform an experiment, write a paper
based on their observations, submits the
paper and reviewers decide whether to
accept or reject it considering their
beliefs, evidence and the style of
paper. And uh this structurality between
the image naming game and scientific
discussion suggests that uh this type of
overall scientific activity can be
regarded as presentation learning
process. This analogy leads us to the
idea of CPC as the model of science. I
believe this work will bring meaningful
implication to philosophy of science and
other field as well.
Okay. So and in this paper actually in
this paper we derived the free energy of
CPC. I have explained before in the
previous slide. So on the base of energy
for CBC framework we can naturally
connect it to active influence. Finally
it extends the individual expected free
energy by incorporating a collective
term. you know this is now can be called
collective epistmic value. So this
formulation allows us to consider active
inference motivated or guided by
emergent language uh symbol W. The
future work includes the exploring this
concept as active influence at the group
level potentially framing it as
collective curiosity or something. You
know in scientific community we we are
conducting research not only collective
curiosity driving scientific exploration
or societal adaptation. Now this is just
the beginning I think and but uh I think
the this kind of approach actually
connecting this has been a kind of long
journey but the the connecting the
simple emergence or how to say the
collective learning process forming the
some external representation not only
just a token of a sequence of token or
category something like that that the
scientific knowledge or laws and so on.
So modeling such kind of social
phenomena is a huge challenge for us and
future AI I think future AI. Okay. So uh
that's almost all of my talk. The
summary is something like this. We
propose a corrective predictive coding
and uh and uh and uh that it was the
uh that was from the simple emergence as
decentralization influence and that was
extended to the free energy principle
and active influence uh to the societal
level and uh I mentioned the the
relationship between LM and the kind of
the the I'll say the the world modeling
and uh we introduced generative emergent
communication and related works and
lastly the I uh I mentioned several
implications in including CPC as a model
of science and system 0123 uh quadratic
process model okay uh that's all for
today thank you very much so these are
the main differences is I added this to
the to today's abstract. So if you uh
interested in uh please uh take a look.
Okay. Thank you very
much. Awesome. Thank you for that. Lots
in the
presentation. Okay. I'll I'll ask a few
questions I wrote down and read some
questions from the live chat. So what
what is the relationship between
convergence amongst agents in their
symbolic
representation and for example
cooperative social behavior or novel
research? Like what else needs to come
into play beyond just symbolic
representation conformity to
get learning, novelty, pro-social
activity or is this or is the symbol
representation do that work by itself?
Okay. Uh could you copy and paste copy
it to the
chat and uh
[Music]
it does a bit difficult to remember.
Okay. Could
you Okay. What is the relationship
between convergence of symbolic
representation and
uh narrative coherent corporate social
behavior uh Nobel
research.
Okay. That's a very important point
interesting and uh important
point and actually the maybe the
uh that her say so the answer is not a
single one. So for for example
uh regarding the cooperative social
behavior let me take the cooperative
social behavior first.
So the say the in cooperative social
behavior. So we need say and if we play
a cooperative social behavior using
language you so we need some sort of
convergence to uh let them let the
counterpart understand my intention. So
actually so such kind of how say
convergence of symbolic representation
uh symbolic external symbol system uh
allow us to
collaborate but before that we need to
construct form the symbolic system
simple system like language you know
this itself is a kind of social
cooperation cooperative behavior. So for
example, Michael Thomas the who is the
very famous the I would say the linguist
and the developmental scientist the he
put the who put much emphasis on
cooperative behavior the as a kind of
origin of language learning and
interestingly from the viewpoint of CPC
kind of the cooperative behavior is
treated as a kind of very much innate
stuff innate like stuff. So
uh can can I go back to the okay let me
go back to the metrop game. So in our uh
point of view so usually usually the the
how say the pre previous approach the
convention approach to emergent
communication.
So as forming uh forming the language is
a model as a part of kind of policy
learning or something the kind of
expressive cooperation the have
maximizing reward or something but here
oops uh sorry here the we don't have any
reward so basically the what do I we
assumed
is is the uh is the joint attention.
Joint attention and also the we assumed
this rejection or acceptance that uh
determine whether the accept or reject
the based on their own
uh belief state.
So as a result the kind of shared
language uh
cooperatively cooperatively uh shared or
formed. So this is a kind of the this is
uh how cooperative behavior but it's not
about the the policy learning you know
but uh but the kind of the process of
cooperative world modeling.
So and this is a very much different uh
viewpoint and this is a kind the first
point of the so so in other words
convergence of symbolic system
representation itself is a cooperative
social. So this is the first answer and
the second answer is uh no research. Uh
maybe this is about the CPC MS uh
collective predictive coding as the
model of science and yes so as you know
as you know or the as we understand this
is a kind of optimization process re but
the we uh how say I think that most of
us don't believe this process reaches
share the kind of convergence you know
that we are always have to struggling to
minimize the free energy and take
actions you know so and uh as a kind of
the you know the collective behavior CPC
try to minimize the I said try to uh
minimize the social level collectively
energy and To that end, the each
researcher each researcher is something
like
this. This looks like controlled by the
you know scientific society but uh they
need to explore explorer to obtain new
data to update the the uh how say the uh
simple system with new information. So
and this is
corresponding to the novel research that
in our society I think. Okay.
Uh is that's from my side. Thank you.
Yeah I really like this image. It's like
humans as the blanket or the interface
between a disembodied symbolic system
and a world that evades symbolic
description alone. Um, okay. I'll ask
another question and then I'll look for
questions in the live chat and I put it
in the chat. So you brought up this dual
view of neural plasticity in terms of
our learning and symbolic plasticity in
terms of the development of symbol
systems. So with access to LLMs and
computational semantics, how is human
language changing or how might it
change?
That's very much interesting uh topic
and uh the actually the that is project
I want to start I want to launch
actually this this is a kind of the very
uh new and uh the interesting topic and
I think yeah to be honest I don't have
answer now but uh with the lens of CPC I
can uh how Hey uh uh I can uh have I say
the discussion over this topic and uh
sorry uh let me move to
the genative. Okay this one this one
this one. So of course the will give us
a huge impact and uh but that also
depends on the in what way the we we in
the future we learn we run the algorithm
system. Actually two years ago, two
years ago the GPD4 was launched and at
that time everybody started using GPD
and everything every linguistic
phenomena on internet is affected by
single. So but recently the situation is
changing and uh the LM becomes
diversified. So the situation has
changed. But uh anyway the our uh how
say our communication our language is is
uh has been affecting by the LM and the
empirical evidences show some effect has
already shown uh some effects. So the
the kind of the word choice uh has
already be changed to some extent but uh
you know the people tend to
think is some thing like a area or
something like a kind of the very much
different from human I'll say human
cognitive system you know humans and but
uh you know if the m the follows
based on the as how say language
generated by
CBC. So basically the distribution
is very much how say naturalistic one
you know we we a
human created the language and uh and
maybe that we can use this figure. So
the they are behind the there are so
many humans people. So just the
summarize the information and give you
influence. So actually that is uh her
say that is similar to uh what has was
happening in the past like this. So
language system was uh we we shared and
we our way of speaking way of writing is
affected by some you know some uh how
say the shared symbol system. Of course
the the distribution of nature is become
very much different. So maybe that leads
us to different uh way of language use.
But um yes and I think the I would say
the you know we cannot uh we I think we
cannot determine oh this is the future
or something like that but uh we can
discuss the how to say
the future you know uh the future
changes based on using the model of the
CPC you know model of symbol emergence.
you know the the if we can model the the
whole background of L so that may enrich
the our
discussion so maybe next year or next
next year I will have a clear
answer I don't know thank you very much
question all right I'll read the next
question ML Dawn wrote In the collective
predictive coding hypothesis paper, the
generative model does not seem to have
any mechanism to capture the dynamics of
the world. This is surprising since the
paper keeps referring to the dynamic
nature of the world repeatedly. If my
observation is correct, may I suggest to
add at the very least x as well as dxdt
to the generative model. This can help
immensely when the world is truly
dynamic. So yeah, how did any of these
papers deal with potential change
through time of the reference or of the
semiosis? Thank you very much. uh no
objection, no defense and I totally
agree with you and uh actually so when I
when I when I uh proposed the metrop
name game and uh actually the uh uh CBC
so we didn't yes the as the first as the
first step we didn't involve the
temporal nature and dynamic nature
And uh it was a kind of strategic uh
one. And uh we wanted to focus on the
this uh how I said this part you know to
connecting the you know the connecting
the collective learning or symbol
emergence process at the group level and
the representation learning in the uh
individual level. And also we have been
conducting research on the world
modeling and the predictive learning
like stuff. And so the actually we
thought that I thought that we can
extend we can invoke the dynamic nature
after that and actually that we wrote uh
and we wrote the some papers about the
kind of the uh how say the the merch the
the uh collective
predictive learning based approach
coding based approach
uh based the meth uh margin learning
with emergency communication and also uh
it's the I I we haven't published that
but uh the our students is now working
on the world model based world how said
emergent communication based on world
model and so on and of course the say uh
we haven't invented that but uh yes I
really that we want to how say
reformulate this kind of process based
on dynamical systems based approach and
uh yeah I we have a discussion over that
with our collaborator and friends that
uh yes that I think so such kind if you
if you are somebody uh some great
researchers add such kind of aspect to
this this kind of CPC like idea that was
hugely that is very great and that's
actually also why uh we I I wanted to
have said join this live stream you know
so in the active influence community
there are so many great researchers who
uh I think who can add the another value
uh or another well uh say nice idea nice
combination to this kind of how say the
research bridging collective behavior
and the uh individual learning process.
So yes so so yes thank you very much for
your
comment. Thank
you.
Um, sort of in closing, what are you
looking forward to this year or how
might people get involved beyond like
reading the papers?
Thank you very much. So uh last year so
after I got the
inspiration of shitishi that I last we
rushed to write several papers and uh I
wanted uh I wanted to share uh this uh
how to say uh this idea and I think that
this will be a kind of a streams of uh
this will say the how the the following
streams of researches and in Japan uh we
I I have now uh have said uh made
several uh many collaborators but u but
uh if you think this is in uh how say
this is an interesting aspect but it's
insufficient please
uh how say uh how say uh I'll say uh
please add another value or another
contribution uh to the to the to the
research community and active influence
community as well. And actually the last
year and the year before last I really
wanted to join the IW
uh AI Dubai in there workshop on active
influence and uh yes my friend uh Tessia
was a keynote speaker last year actually
because of some
universities job or something I couldn't
uh attend the meeting that this year I
really want to join But if I miss the I
my I'll say my collaborator or my
students will join the and I hope that
we can have a fruitful collaboration or
discussion in the pen and not only the
in person but also the online as well.
Uh I welcome the any any messages or any
tweets are welcome to and and I'm the
kind of the long-term Twitter or ex user
and uh yes and uh please uh keep in
touch. Thank you very
much. Thank you. It was an awesome
presentation. I hope people in the
community read these papers and start to
build and work with them. So, I hope to
keep in touch and see you again. See you
again. Thank you very much. Bye.